um first I'd like to just start out
getting your general reaction today to
the impeachment hearings on the hill do
you feel that if Democrats made their
case and how did you feel about the
Republican performance you're talking
about the witch-hunt is that what you
mean is that what you're talking about I
hear it's a joke I haven't watched I
haven't watched for one minute because
I've been with the president which is
much more important as far as I'm
concerned this is a sham and shouldn't
be allowed it was a situation that was
caused by people that shouldn't have
allowed it to happen I want to find out
who is the whistleblower because the
whistleblower gave a lot of very
incorrect information including my call
with the president of Ukraine which was
a perfect call and highly appropriate
and he wrote something that was much
different than the fact I want to find
out why the IG why would he have
presented that when in fact all he had
to do is check the call itself and he
would have seen it I'm gonna be
releasing I think on Thursday a second
call which actually was the first of the
two and you'll make a determination as
to what you think there but I've heard
just a report they said it's all
third-hand information
nothing direct at all it can't be direct
because I never said it and all they
have to do is look very very simply at
the transcript if you read the
transcript this was analyzed by great
lawyers this was analyzed by Gregg Jared
it was analyzed by Mark Levin it was
analyzed by everybody they said this
statement that I made the whole call
that I made with the president of
Ukraine was a perfect one so that this
country gets put through that that we
have to waste this gentleman's time by
even thinking about it talking about it
I'd much rather focus on peace in the
Middle East and I hear that it's I hear
that it's a hoax and it's being played
as a hoax that's what I hear but you'll
have to tell me go ahead